people love this car everybody even my
surfer dude friends couldn't resist the
classic cool of this gilded tank since
its birth into mass production nearly 40
years ago the Mercedes g-class hasn't
needed any Nick's or tucks to its
handsome body and stunning face
on the road the g-wagen drives like you
might expect it's tight with not a lot
of give anywhere the steering is great
as are the big beautiful phrase but
you're in for a bumpy ride acceleration
in this five thousand-pound car is
astounding you'll hit 60 miles per hour
and 5.2 seconds the car has a 6.0 liter
v12 Biturbo engine it has 621 horsepower
and 738 foot-pounds of torque plus
permanent all-wheel drive and three
independent differential locks which
we're really useful when we got stuck in
the sand the one thing that's undeniable
about this car is it's cool is it two
hundred and twenty four thousand dollars
cool maybe that's a lot of money though
because yes the car has the v12 yes it
has the AMG tuning yes it's a Mercedes
and beautiful inside and outside but
you're still paying a premium for cool
the interior of the G Wagon has an
interesting mix of what I'd call
primitive and luxurious it has a turnkey
ignition no starter button here but
there is also carbon fiber trim seat
heaters hidden cupholders and a well
done entertainment and control system
my surfer dudes did have some complaints
the back seat is really small given the
size of the car and there's another
problem this G 65 AMG gets only 11 miles
per gallon in the city and 13 on the
highway the thing is I like the G Wagon
because it is honest it promises to be a
road dominating luxurious I kind of cool
and it delivers exactly that
you